just talk us through high level what are
the latest developments in ukraine yes
the the war itself is going on across a
front of uh 2 400 kilometers all the way
around most of the attention is on the
south of ukraine uh around kershan and
in the kirsten region um
yeah two 2 400 kilometers in the kershan
region itself uh the
offensive which the ukrainians are
conducting is going on in quite a big
arc and there are reports that uh
they're as far south as tom yeah balker
which is really quite close to the south
park ocean right round to uh valleca
castronka and that's important because
it controls the road to novakovka what
the ukrainians are trying to do is to
stretch the russians who although
they've got good equipment to this area
west of the nipah river they are short
of troops they're actually shorter
troops on the ground and that's their
problem the ukrainians are now trying to
stretch them in different directions
and then just uh to give us some idea uh
how important is carson to the russians
well it's very important because if the
russians felt that they were going to
lose kirsten or if they if they feel
that they're going to get surrounded
west of the nepa then they would have
the choice of withdrawing from cursing
or trying to reinforce it now they could
reinforce it they've got a very big unit
training in russia it's in its
pre-deployment training um just outside
fairway outside moscow
at molino that's its pre-deployment
training it's got a long way to go if it
were to get closer and that's um it's
the third combined army corps 30 or 40
000 troops they've got the best tanks
the t-80s the t-90 tanks so they're
ready to go or soon ready to go if they
had to move they could easily get by
rail to belgorod that's a straight
internal movement they could get through
the
people's republics through the occupied
territories towards crimea but could
they get to kirsten because the
ukrainians have taken down all the
bridges yeah and so if the russians
wanted to use this new army corps to
reinforce cursing then it would become a
battle of the bridges and we'd see how
that goes that's a long way in the
future but that's the choice the
russians might be faced with if they're
under real pressure in this attacking
person